soit je vous laisse vous exprimer parce
que j'en avais gros sur la patate pas
que bois mais oui j'ai une grosse
charlotte pour toi franck à y aller oui
valeurs l'amour tout à fait sans valérie
l'amour c'est il y à peu près 40 ans et
organique n'est pas nue fait croire
pendant des années qu'ils avaient 35
quand on est allé voir sur wikipédia à
bord de l allée des trucs des trucs leur
vol et leur en coûte on était une bande
de potes de bons potes et après avoir
passé peut-être une après midi dans le
fleuve d'euros
ils savaient vivre service au fleuve
je cherche pas ce que tu dois en avoir
des doutes sur mes parents étant achetés
pour le week-end j'ai organisé une
petite fête à la maison on a fait la
fête
sauf connue d'entre elles dimanche et
sans rentrer dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
et puis je ne suis pas venu tout seul
parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui aie tu t'en
veux énormément parce que ce soir là je
pense que tu as fait une grosse bêtise
pas de sexe y a pas d'enfant sauvette ça
tu as faites entrer l'accusé
on va les jouer émission de merde mais
dans l'ensemble c'est juste vous n'êtes
pas obligé de parler tu les as si tu
veux terminer sa carrière participent à
la vie
[Applaudissements]
public ces chanteurs et comédiens
c'est toi aussi tu terminais ma carrière
se sont joints la grosse chalet situé
rue milliers si tu l'as tuée
[Rires]
si tu dis ça c'est dans les carrières
eux et faire un petit séjour en prison
la grosse salade aujourd'hui après dix
ans d'existence et plus de tenues
carrière brisée alors valérie oui on va
capitule depuis le déficit merde donc
vous êtes aurait 30 au cjc ya combien de
40 chambres 40e et là les parents
doivent des parents de rentrer c'est un
jour plus tard errant kramer et là vous
êtes avec fois qu'il se passe quelque
chose avec franck ou pas non on est
plusieurs quand même
à l'époque c'était très très ouvert il
ya quelqu'un qui veut témoigner qui est
très élevé après franz wiget oui
charenton apprennent à pondérer au matin
allez vas-y tire déjà il dit bonjour ça
ça et c'est pareil c'est tendu
d'attention qu'on y arrive pas car on
sait pas vu ses deux fils de francs
[Rires]
gpat obligés de m'excuser pour un truc
que j'ai c'est ya 40 ans quel est votre
prénom prenez rené bonsoir mais papa
fall et le papa de valérie sion non non
tu étais moins finir il ya un ses potes
là quand je suis rentré dans la maison
tu étais dans le fond et là ils sont
tous repartis sur leurs mobylettes
sauveteurs continuent mais quand j'ai
bougé le fauteuil et schott bien que tu
avais mis dessus la brûlure de cigarette
de la moquette tout neuf
[Applaudissements]
les rations et la ville folle c'est les
amicaux mais derrière la brûlure il y
avait un cadavre alors rené c'est drôle
vous lui en voulez encore une brûlure
j'espère au moins que ça mérite moins
des excuses s'excuse francs que je pense
que tu devrais repayer la moquette
rené je suis désolée pour ce que j'ai
fait à votre moquette
pour le reste vous n'avez pas vu rhône
et je suis désolé
je tenais à féliciter rené pour l'effort
qu'il a fait pour utiliser langage codé
et des métaphores la moquette brûler
tout ça je trouve ça très amusant
[Applaudissements]